to his friends he was the blond Beast to
his enemies he was the hangman of the
butcher of Prague The Nanny devoted his
life to he was the man with the iron
heart during his life
reinhard heydrich was known by many
names to numerous to list here but you
probably associate him with one name in
particular Heydrich was the Nazi target
of operation anthropoid a talented
classical musician who threw it all away
to become a military man Heydrich was
the Nazi ideal made flesh he was told he
was blond cultured a lover of vogner
he was also brutal it was under Heydrich
swatched that the infamous
Einsatzgruppen were formed under his
direction that Nazi enemies were killed
and his designs that the Holocaust was
perpetrated assassinated by Czechoslovak
resistance in Prague in 1942 Heydrich is
a mystery a sensitive cultured boy who
somehow grew up to be one of history's
worst monsters join us today as we
journey into products heart of darkness
[Music]
if you were showing the conditions
Heydrich was born into you and asked
what you thought he would grow up to be
genocide or maniac would probably be
quite far down your list born Reinhard
who can tristan Heydrich on March the
7th 1904 the world baby Reinhard came
into was one of middle class luxury his
father
Bruno was an opera aficionado who ran a
music conservatory in the German town of
howl near Leipzig while his mother
Elizabeth was a pianist from a wealthy
family for young Heydrich that means a
life of culture money and most
importantly music music was the air that
this family breathed Bruno wrote his own
operas and sang on stage while Elizabeth
had little Heydrich trains do exacting
classical standards on the violin and
the cello but there was a cloud hanging
over this family's charms life at clouds
that only really counts as a cloud if
you live surrounded by German
nationalists everyone in ha fault that
Bruno was Jewish then you might be
thinking now well yeah but so what
well Bruno he didn't feel that way he
was
certain his supposed Jewish backgrounds
was why his opera career never really
took off as time went on he began to
loathe the religion he blamed for his
own failings and he made sure that young
Heydrich loathed it too still this
unpleasantness aside their family life
it was relatively normal Elizabeth was a
strict mother determined her son should
succeed and soon Heydrich was not just
an accomplished musician but also a
powerful sportsman there's a normal
family appearance it only began to crack
in 1914 like many Germans the Heinrichs
were first excited by world war ones
outbreak thinking it would be a fairly
easy win for their country but as the
first weeks dragged on and then months
and finally years that optimism it began
to fade in the winter of 1916 to 1917
fuel and food shortages brought on by
that war led to starvation and misery
across the nation in Harlow work at
Bruno's conservatory it dried up as the
economy faltered as 1917 rolled on the
German population grew angry at the
war's management they began striking and
protesting before long the cities were
in turmoil is running street battles
erupted it between the far-right
nationalists and communists Paula wasn't
spared as a teen Heydrich watch left and
right extremists battle for control of
the city's streets unlike his terrified
parents Heydrich found the clashes
intoxicating
in October of 1918 German dreams of
winning the war they finally collapsed
with a resounding crash Germany removed
the Kaiser from power and brought in a
civilian government tasked with
negotiating peace in the aftermath whole
segments of the military went into
rebellion before the war had ended on
November the 11th the country it was in
revolution as a communist uprising
seized control of Berlin Heydrich
decided that he had to make a stand
in haleh the now 16-year old boy had
joined a local fry Corps unit in ten
days as an anti-communist militia the
Frei Corps soon bloomed into a far-right
paramilitary force that targeted Jews
and revolutionaries alike for the
teenaged Heydrich the experience it was
an eye-opener for the first time in his
life he was surrounded by people who
felt like he'd had people who shared his
anti-semitic beliefs and his dislike of
Communists they also shared his desire
to use violence by August the 11th the
country it was back under control the
Vimal Republic was
founded and Germany began to adjust to
its new life as a democratic nation but
the revolution of 1919 it had unleashed
the forces of far ice nationalism and
Heydrich wasn't the only one to heed
their siren call the early days of the
vie Mar Republic were marked by a
never-ending series of political
wildfires on March 13 1920 an
ultra-nationalist pooch captured Berlin
and held the city for a few days before
the government regained control three
years later another right wing pooch
this time in Munich killed 20 people its
leader all that was Adolphe Hitler now
you might be expecting to hear that
Heydrich was in the thick of all of this
cheering on the Nazi Party but you'd be
wrong
after the fry Corps disbanded Heydrich
had hung around in Harley just long
enough to get his high-school diploma in
1922 then hit hightailed it out of his
hometown as fast as he could
but he hadn't gone running to the Nazi
Party Heydrich instead had joined the
German Navy by 1922 Vimal Germany was in
the grip of hyperinflation the economy
it was in ruins anyone who wanted a roof
over their head and three square meals a
day while they joined the military and
Heydrich he wanted more than that
now a lad of eighteen he was ambitious
he wanted to become an admiral he still
flirted with the fart rice maintaining
membership of the anti-semitic Deutsche
shoots on Troost Bund
but while most future high-ranking Nazis
were passionate true believers who were
willing to forego a normal life for
their cause Heydrich here wasn't like
that he wanted a respectable career with
responsibilities when Hitler published
mine come from his jail cell in 1925
Heydrich didn't even bother to read it
by 1928 Heydrich diligent good work had
paid off him to be promoted to first
lieutenant and assigned to Navy
intelligence while he was still taunted
for his supposed to Jewish roots the
bullying he used to receive for his
cultured side it was long gone now a
grown man Heydrich sensitive qualities
they were no longer a burden in fact
they made in something of a cache
throughout the late 1920s and early
1930s Heydrich sowed his Wild Oats like
a man hoping to rival the Quakers
in breakfast production it was during
this seductive phase that Heydrich met
Lina von Osten aged just 19 Lina was
everything Heydrich wanted in a woman
she was charming intelligence and in or
of him she was also a fervent National
Socialist by the 1930s the Nazis they
were well known in Germany but they
weren't yet in charge when Heydrich
first met Lina he actually made fun of
her for being a Nazi calling the
leadership clowns and to riding girls as
crippled little did the ambitious sailin
know that it was only a few short months
away from joining those clowns in early
1931 Heydrich proposed to Lina he then
forwarded a copy of the engagement
announcement to another girl that he was
seeing as a way of breaking up with her
but Heydrich sploshy methods soon
returned to bite his Germanic ash when
the girl's father founds the
announcements and hit the roof
he actually complained to the Navy and
the Navy responded by actually firing
Heydrich on April the 30th 1931 Heydrich
he was discharged when he got the news
the future butcher of Prague locked
himself in his room and he cried like a
baby
for days on end when Heydrich finally
emerged from his epic cry upon Linda was
basically like man this is perfect you
could absolutely now get a job with the
Nazis this will be great at first
Heydrich he wasn't enthusiastic his main
sticking point was that he didn't think
they were good enough career prospects
but Lina kept pushing him and eventually
he joined up a becoming member five
hundred and forty four thousand nine
hundred and sixteen and this was the
beginning of a rise towards infamy
[Music]
at this point you might be wondering how
hydric the lothario sailor became hydra
cannot see the answer is surprisingly
his grandmother by the time Heydrich
joins the Nazis his mother and
grandmother were already enthusiastic
members and that carried their wealth
and connections into their new lives
within a month of Heydrich joining his
grandmother had arranged private meeting
between Heydrich and SS leader heinrich
himmler it has got to be said that
Himmler wasn't all that happy the only
thing that convinced him to go was that
Hydra grandmother had inflated her
grandkids connections to Naval
Intelligence which might be useful to
the Nazi Party when the two met in
Munich INLA curtly gave Heydrich 20
minutes to outline a counterintelligence
operation for the Nancy party 20 minutes
later the Blackshirts leader collected
his jaw off the floor and offered
Heydrich an job Heydrich had absolutely
a ste interview despite only ever
holding a low position in naval
intelligence he managed to use all of
his knowledge to outline an effective
strategy when he had a blank spot in his
knowledge he improvised using the plots
of half-remembered spy novels and
surprisingly this totally works Himmler
recruited Heydrich into the SD the SS
intelligence branch right then and there
this was the beginning of a partnership
that would eventually leave Europe in
utter ruins
although Himmler is infamous in his own
right he and Heydrich could be seen as a
bit of a double act the Laurel and Hardy
of mass murder during the night of the
Long Knives in 1934 Himmler and Heydrich
they worked together to exterminate the
power holders in the SA the Nazi round
shots one of those killed was sa leader
Ernst röhm Godfather - Heydrich sonant
child in the aftermath Himmler awarded
Heydrich by promoting him to chief of
the Gestapo it was just the first in a
series of events that were gonna label
Himmler promoting Heydrich like crazy in
drian of 1936 for example Himmler merged
the SD the German Criminal Police and
the Gestapo into a single unit and gave
it to Heydrich three years later in
September 1939
him--let consolidated every single
intelligence operation across the entire
third reich and a Heydrich the new Reich
security main office rsha was so
powerful even other Nazis were kept in
the dark about its very existence not
that Heydrich
didn't earn his new position for a guy
who once called the Nazis clowns
Heydrich had taken to his new job like a
fascist dr. water in November 1938 had
directly organized the looting and
burning of Jewish property known as the
Crystal nacht a year later in August of
1939 Heydrich had also masterminded the
false flag attack on galavis
gave the Nazis a pretext for invading
Poland in fact many of the most infamous
Nazi actions can be traced back to this
one opera lover from Harley after the
invasion of Poland in September of 1939
for example Heydrich was put in charge
of the Einsatzgruppen the Einsatzgruppen
were death squads that followed in the
wake of invading German army is mopping
up the enemies of the Reich their
brutality it was legendary in the first
three months after the occupation of
Poland's they murdered fifty thousand
people when the Nazis pushed east in
1941 it was even worse over 33,000 Jews
were killed in just two days in Kiev by
the Einsatzgruppen not that Heydrich
screams only happened broad in 1939 as
Germany went to war Heydrich had
instructed his security service to focus
on the Reich's internal enemies in the
dying days of that year officers fanned
out across German territory liquidating
gypsies freemasons homosexuals jehovah's
witnesses and intellectuals taken
together it was a tsunami of bloodshed a
wave of annihilation unlike anything
Europe had seen for generations and the
worst well it was yet to come
[Music]
on November the 12th 1938 reinhard
heydrich reported on the jewish question
to a gathering of Nazis referring to
Europe's Jews is the eternal subhuman he
declared that imprisoning them would not
be enough and that the Reich would have
to get rid of them completely not three
months later Hermann Goering took
Heydrich to one side and told him to
solve the Jewish problem at this stage
what Goering meant was a policy of
forced emigration and brutal tactics
that would chase the Jews out of Germany
but even in early 1939 it was clear that
the blonde beast wouldn't stop at
emigration it started after the invasion
of Poland as the Einsatzgruppen were
unleashing hell Heydrich and Adolf
Eichmann quietly worked together to have
all of Austria's Jews rounded up and
deport it
later that year Heydrich directed the
opening of Guetta's and bloods Krakow
and Warsaw he ensured conditions within
them was so bad that hundreds of
thousands would just die of disease
although extermination was not yet
official Reich policy Heydrich knew what
his superiors really wanted to do and
alongside his old buddy Himmler he set
out to ensure that it would happen in
May 1941 Heydrich issued an order
forbidding Jews to leave the Reich
claiming a final solution was being
prepared on July 31st that year the Nazi
High Command gave Heydrich its blessing
to devise a workable plan for his final
solution it was from these black and
twisted roots that the poisoned fruit of
the Holocaust was born
now many people were implicit in the
Holocaust not least Hydrox BFF Himmler
ins we don't want to let them off the
hook by making it appear like it was all
Heydrich swak alone they're being said
the blonde beast was intimately involved
in planning the 20th century's worst
genocide On January the 20th 1942
Heydrich summons leading Nazis to the
Berlin suburb of 1c for a conference
over a three-course lunch Heydrich led a
genial discussion on his plans to rid
Europe of its Jews his idea was to march
all 11 million East letting them die
through starvation exposure along the
way the survivors would then be interred
in labor camps and worked to death with
any that persistently survived finally
being exterminated by a hand when the
von C conference disbanded the fate of
the Reich's Jews
it had been sealed the Holocaust was now
official Nazi policy and his chief
architect was determined to get started
as soon as possible that Heydrich was
not going to live to see his murderous
idea made flesh vengeance was about to
come from a very unlikely source
Reiner Heydrich wasn't aware of it as he
stepped out into the cold Berlin air
after the von Z conference but far away
two men were already plotting his murder
their names were yang kubis and jozef
gabcik they were format Czechoslovak
citizens who'd escaped abroad and been
trained by British intelligence these
two men were going to kill the blond
Beast the wheels of fate that would set
Heydrich Kubb assured gabcik on a
collision course it first began turning
nearly three and a half years earlier in
early October of 1938 the governments of
France and Britain had agreed to the
German annexation of Czechoslovakia
Sudetenland region of course this turned
out to be a case of give the Nazis an
engines they'll take your entire country
and five months later German troops
invaded Czechoslovakia in Slovakia a
Nazi puppet regime was installed while
the area of modern-day Czech Republic
became the Protectorate of Bohemia and
Moravia under direct German rule the
German invasion of Czechoslovakia it
wasn't as brutal as later invasions like
those of Poland and the USSR Czech
industry was considered too vital to the
German war efforts to risk disrupting so
the Nazi mass executions of the periods
usually involved dozens rather than
hundreds or thousands of victims in fact
the Nazis were so comparatively
soft-touch in the Protectorate that a
healthy resistance movement sprang up
engaging in frequent acts of sabotage it
was this sabotage that brought Heydrich
onto the scene on September the 24th
1941 Hitler sacked the former protector
of bohemia and moravia in a fit of pique
at all these insolent Czechs playing a
fake to his glorious Reich in place of
the old guy Heydrich was called in to
whip prague into shape Heydrich was not
a fan of Czechs prior to his posting had
referred to his new subjects as the
Czech vermin on arriving in Prague he
arranged to have a hundred and forty two
people hanged in just five days was a
mission statement a promise of the blood
that would flow through the cobbled
streets of Prague if the Czechs did not
start playing nice
it was also Heydrich Sohn death warrants
in London the Czechoslovak
government-in-exile watched Heydrich
takers new posting with a feeling of
impotence already the exiled Czechs and
Slovaks were unpopular among their
British hosts for their apparent
unwillingness to take heart action while
the Polish pilots were shooting down
German bombers in the French
Sterns was engaging in life-or-death
escapades the checks were seemingly
content to just sabotage a few factories
the Exile government needed a piece of
concrete heroism that they could show
the world to prove that they weren't the
weak partners in the fight against Nazi
rule in Heydrich they found the perfect
cause on October 3rd 1941 the exiled
Czechoslovak government informed
Britain's Special Operations Executive
that they were going to assassinate
Heydrich the Brits at that point were
pretty much like wow you guys are gonna
do something that would be great Thanks
less than a month later Slovak Warrant
Officer Yusuf garvik was chosen for the
special mission he was initially joined
by Czech soldier Karel Svoboda but
Swoboda injured himself and was replaced
by Czech staff sergeants Yarn Jewish two
months later just after Christmas
coefficient gabcik parachuted alongside
several Czechoslovak commandos into the
wintry landscape outside Prague under
the cover of night as the men moved
silently through the snow towards the
distant glow of the ancient city the
citizens of Bohemia they slept soundly
in their beds no one could have known
the firestorm that was about to be
unleashed
the name chosen for the plan to
assassinate Heydrich was Operation
anthropoid a word which means resembling
a human it was the perfect name for a
plan to assassinate the most inhuman
human of all back in Prague Heydrich had
spent his few short months as protector
pacifying first the city and then the
country the capital had seen the
promised bloodshed with some 400
civilians being sent to the gallows in
the wider Protectorate around five
thousand had been imprisoned and
tortured but Heydrich Halland was gone
in guns blazing and new swinging it was
widely accepted that treating the Czechs
like the poles would hamper the German
war effort
so he'd deployed kindness as well under
Heydrich rations had been increased
wages have been raised and Pensions
subsidized it was a cynical move
straight out of the far-right playbook
stuff gold down populations throats to
distract them from your crimes
and it also worked a spring 1942
year-old interview Heydrich was able to
report the checks were pacified his
carrot and machine-gun tactics have seen
sabotage rates plummet factory
productivity it was booming Nazi
occupation seemed so accepted that
Heydrich even felt comfortable motoring
around Prague in an open-topped car with
only a handgun and his armed driver for
protection but Prague it wasn't quite as
pacified as Heydrich thought somewhere
in the old alleyways of the city kuba sh
and gabcik laid low in the house of an
unsuspecting family plotting their next
move that made contact with the Czech
resistance months ago and we're now
feeling deeply frustrated a plan to
assassinate Heydrich on a road near his
house had been called off at the last
minute another plan to kill him on a
train had also been aborted that now
been in Prague for nearly five months
and Heydrich he was still alive it was
at this point that someone suggested
killing Heydrich on his morning drive to
work on Heydrich is regular route there
was a hairpin corner anyone driving
around it would have to slow to a near
crawl in other words it was the perfect
place to kill someone in an open-topped
car on the morning of May the 27th 1942
gabcik and kuba SH waited in a tram stop
by the corner they were dressed in
civilian clothes but there was nothing
innocent about them under his coat garb
Schick had a Sten gun while kuba she had
an anti-tank grenade hidden in his
briefcase as the city came to life
around them the two
and waited for their date with destiny
shortly after they arrived Heydrich
Skaar came interview as predicted the
driver slowed down for the corner gabcik
casually stepped into the street turned
and opened fire with his submachine gun
at least that was the plan what really
happened was that gap chicks gun jams as
he tried frantically to fire the fatal
shot Heydrich Succession turned from one
of surprise to white-hot hangar ordering
his driver to stop Heydrich grabbed his
own gun and raised it a guard check the
slave AK just had time to see the barrel
train on him when the explosion hit the
second Heydrich scar had stopped cubish
had hurled his briefcase bomb it was
actually off target the grenade exploded
behind the car knocking all three men
down but killing no-one Heydrich
staggered to his feet and opened fire on
kuba SH but the blasted stunned him and
the bullets went wild cubish grabbed a
bicycle and escaped certain that the
assassination had failed screaming at
his drive to get that bastard Heydrich
ran after gabcik firing at the Slovak
sprinting form they ran one Street and
then two when something odd happened
Heydrich the consummate sportsman found
that he couldn't run he was out of
breath after a couple of hundred meters
he collapsed on the ground raised the
hand to his side came away sticky with
blood the briefcase bomb it had missed
its target was the shrapnel it not the
rear of the car was torn to bits lump of
jagged metal had been propelled deep
inside of Heydrich body the blonds
beasts didn't know it but he was already
dead
in the end it took reinhard heydrich
eight whole days to die for a while it's
actually looked as if he might recover
but then septicemia set in and the
cultured young man from Harley passed
away on June the fourth the response it
was immediate in Berlin Hitler demanded
the heads of 10,000 checks On June the
10th SS units walked into the Czech
village of liditz a and fulfilled the
Fuhrer as demand all the men and boys of
liditz a were shot dead and all the
women and girls were loaded into trucks
and sent to concentration camps when it
was discovered eleven men were outside
of the village on business Nazi agents
were sent to track them down and murder
them too
all of the pets and animals in the
village they were rounded up and shot
finally the buildings were set on fire
the Nazis films the whole thing
intending that did say to be a warning
to the world in Prague revenge mass
killings were carried out resulting in
1,300 dead another Czech village their
Jacky was targeted and also destroyed it
was like the Angel of Death had swept
across the lands like Heydrich spicyness
soul was carrying out one last killing
spree before returning to hell three
weeks after the assassination a Czech
collaborator Carole Chadha passed on the
hiding place of gabcik and kuba Sh to
the Gestapo the two assassins were in
the basement of Prague's Cathedral love
since cyril and methodius on June the
18th 1942 700 soldiers converged on the
Church gabcik and cubish held them off
for some hours before committing suicide
in the cathedral crypts the bullet holes
from the firefight they can still be
seen to this very day in the West their
reaction to Heydrich assassination was
equally swift and decisive the image of
the descend flames spurred the Allies to
tear up the Munich Agreement until this
moment in 1942 it was still possible
that a post-war settlement might allow
the Germans to keep the Sudetenland with
the images of let's say fresh in
everyone's minds that was simply no
longer an option it was thanks to this
one assassination that Czechoslovakia
was able to remain a nation after World
War two what about Heydrich Heydrich was
the only high-ranking Nazi to be
assassinated in the whole of World War
two a factor that explains our continued
fascination with him but beyond
operation anthropoid Heydrich deserves
to be remembered he was the man who
outlines the blueprint for the
Holocaust the man who controlled the
infamous Einsatzgruppen it was under his
watch that the notorious Polish ghettos
were creators had he lived longer its
undoubtable that he would have committed
more atrocities unlike every other
leading Nazi there's no indication
Heydrich was a true believer in the
early days or an opportunist who took a
job to please his fiancee and then did
that job with bloodthirsty relish in
many ways that makes him even scarier
than someone like his old buddy Himmler
we like to think of people as either
inherently good or inherently evil but
Heydrich he wasn't inherently anything
he was just a blank Halle man in another
life he would probably have made a
boringly average and naval commander but
Heydrich he didn't live another life he
lived this one with all its bloodshed in
the end perhaps all we can say is that
the shy sensitive boy from Harley was
simply the perfect anthropoid a creature
that looked human without ever feeling
the faintest flicker of humanity so I'm
just gonna end it there though asking
for likes or subscribes stuff like that
just I hope you found this video
informative and I'll see you next time
[Music]